- [Audience Member]
So, here's my question.
If you could have a sit down
with anyone from history, or fictional,
who would it be?
- Randy 'The Macho Man' Savage.
(cheers)
("Handskin" by Spacio)
- [Babin] Yeah,
I don't know if you've
seen in the comments but...
- People loved it right?
I knew it, I knew it, you know?
- [Babin] Yeah.
- It was great, right,
yeah I did see the initial
buzz but then I got busy.
- My question is,
what is the biggest thing you've learned
from either an individual that's under 18
or just the general
public that's under 18.
- Love this question.
- I'm curious what you're picking up.
Appreciate it.
- Great question,
I'm religious about 18 and under.
You know, I don't spend...
I'm trying to think of
an individual under 18
that's taught me something.
I'm sure, nothing pops to mind
but the whole culture
teaches me a ton.
It was very early on, Musical.ly,
if I could do a quick recall here
of my episode with Baby Ariel
who's now become mainstream on Instagram
and music and she's just gonna be a beast.
Have you discovered music
that you would have never known about.
- Yes.
- Without Musical.ly...
- A lot, yes.
- That has changed the things you like
and things that nature.
- Yeah, I have...
How many Musical.ly videos?
450-ish, and most of them
I got through out other people.
So it's cool, you're exploring
different styles of music
that I had never thought I would listen to
just on a regular basis
and I learned
a lot of words to all the songs.
- Everyone's like, "you know the words,"
and I'm like on the radio
I'm like, "oh yeah I know
that from Musical.ly,
"I did that one."
- But sometimes I only know
15 seconds of a certain song.
- Me too I only know the hook.
The fact that I had an interview with her
four years ago, or three years ago,
two years, whatever.
It's pretty epic.
I learn a lot from under 18.
To me, watching 14 to 18
is pretty much what I most care about.
Even going lower,
watching how the...
Watching all the eight year old girls
become experts in making slime
and then reverse engineering it,
on how much Youtube kids
and a couple Instagram accounts
and some Snapchat exploring.
Really
I would tell you that almost
everything I learned comes from that.
It's really funny how obsessed I am
with nine to 18.
That is the culture to me.
What they like, you know,
"Oh cool, face tattoos are
good for them now, cool."
They will teach me pretty much everything
and it's interesting as you get older.
It's interesting as I've gotten older
I've gotten more in tune with 14 to 18,
not the other way around.
So it's taught me...
It's reinforced something
I've always known,
which is when you're 14, 15, 16,
you wanna establish your shit.
You don't want your older brother's stuff,
you don't want your parent's stuff
and that means you, AKA all of you,
will create the next thing.
And if I can watch it and understand it,
it will give me insight
into where it's going
and gen z for me is a sweet spot.
For me, for Vayner Media,
and most of what I'm doing.
- [Babin] If you're not an entrepreneur.
- Yep.
- [Babin] And you wanna become
the best number 2 or
number 3 in a company.
- Yep.
- [Babin] What should be the strategy?
- There's a lot of strategies
with that question,
there's two ways to go about it.
One, overall, you wanna be
a great number two or three,
I think you need to figure out
and spend as much time with number ones
and try to see patterns in them
and see if your skillsets match to them.
But if it's specific,
like if you work Wine
Library or Vayner Media or
a great SAS company or a Tesla,
I don't care what it is.
You need to reverse
engineer the individual.
You need to reverse engineer her.
You need to look at the
number one in your company,
the C.O. you need to say,
"alright, this is what Sally's into,
"this is what she's good at,
"that's what she's bad at,
"this is what she likes,
"this is what she appreciates."
For example,
being a good two, three,
four of intermedia
is pretty simple.
I'm going to care if you're capable
of being the bigger person.
Empathy, a leader that
leads, positive energy.
You're not...
You could sell a trillion
dollars in my company,
if you're a dick face you're gonna lose.
So, that works with me.
A lot of other people
who are pandering to short-term cash
don't care if you're nice at all
if you can make a ton of money,
that's what they need right now
because they're about
to go public or sell.
So you wanna be able to be
an infrastructure for that.
So you have to really reverse
engineer the number one
and then, number one's
have a lot of cliches.
They tend to be entrepreneurial,
artistic, chaotic.
Really, to me, great number
two, three, four, fives,
very often are bringing
unbelievable organization skills,
capacity skills, empathy,
just a lot of those
kinds of things as well.
So crossing T's and dotting I's which,
I'm incapable of, and that's
why I got D's and F's.
But boy, do I need Marcus and James,
and Allen, and Jeff, and even Andre
and Justine, that's what they have to do.
'Bout to do the dinner
series that we're doing,
doing the speeches across the country
and the organization, customer resources
that pick me up for all these talks
asked me to do some add-on events.
Strategy sessions and dinner sessions and
they've been a lot of fun.
10, 15 guys or gals in Houston.
Much longer we've been to Florida,
nice little group here.
In Denver, I'm enjoying them.
I like people, I like interaction,
I think it creates content potentially.
Teams aren't often the same
but we'll see what happens.
But I'm excited about tonight.
Got home at 1 A.M last
night from meetings,
and had to get up at 5:30
and then flew all day
and now I'm on East Coast time in Denver
so these are some of the days
you have to grind through, right?
Big fan of six, seven,
eight hours of sleep.
Sometimes you do get four.
Sometimes in that same time you got four,
you also have to schlep across the country
and then stay out late.
It's, you know, it is what it fuckin' is.
So, but we gotta be on, you're on.
Hey.
- What's up.
How you doin' man?
- My career
is really quite more predicated on
psychology and intuition
and respecting math completely
but not letting it dictate my behavior
which is what I think
smart people allow...
If I sat here, if all of you said to me,
"all of us are gonna cap out."
Like, why,
if a genie walked in and said,
"Gary, people, all of these men
"will only cap out."
The easy answer is you didn't bet on art.
- [Blond Man] (mutters)
- Yeah...
- [Blond Man] Then you don't
have the right processes.
- To me,
the reason people hit ceilings,
is they let math dictate.
- I don't understand what you're saying.
- I'll explain it.
When you think about
everybody sitting here
you think about the value,
even the questions you're asking,
how much you're making per employee.
People let math...
Math is incredible to a point
and then it becomes your enemy.
- [Blond Man] Yeah.
- The thing that makes you successful
is then the thing that
becomes your detriment.
How are you?
("Handskin" by Spacio)
Thank you.
How are you?
Hello, hello.
- [Man Off-Screen] In
the last couple of years
to be placed in a similar space.
They're not doing things
based around teams.
They're doing things around more like,
finding the right people.
- Of course.
- [Man Off-Screen] (mutters)
- Yep.
- [Man Off-Screen] They've
taken massive funding.
- Yeah.
- [Man Off-Screen] Hundred million,
all these budgets and they're throwing it
into Facebook into media.
And it's like there's
a whole new arena now.
We're still very well known,
but it's this pressure that we have to...
We're gonna have to get
into that arena to...
- From who, pressure from who?
- [Man Off-Screen] Well...
- 'Cause I'm goin' through this...
Babin literally heard this argument,
me being on this...
On the other side of that pressure
in my own company
on the way to the airport yesterday.
Which is, I'm not gonna let
(beeps) and other media publishers funding
dictate my behavior
because it's a marathon.
I love when people raise too much money.
It means they're in trouble.
- [Man Off-Screen] Yeah.
- And then I'm gonna ask you
the most important question.
And this is why I'm gonna win,
in my world, from whom
is my employees, my...
Things of that nature
but there's nobody that has any say.
When you say all this pressure,
I heard you say it,
it's self-funded.
- [Man Off-Screen] It is, yeah.
- Cool, so how many partners, if any,
do you have?
- None at the moment.
- Good, so then you're talking
about yourself to yourself?
As one person.
Who's got the next loudest voice besides
your own voice in your head to yourself.
- [Man Off-Screen] Well it's the team.
Like the other thing...
- No, but it's not the team, right?
If this is the team, in any team,
it's her then him.
In that team, who's got the loudest voice
of all this pressure,
there's your own competitive pressure.
There's you.
Which is number one, two, and three.
I'm just curious to give
you the best answer,
who number four is, who number five is,
because those become the
interesting questions.
Because I think what
you're gonna realize is,
there isn't.
This is what everybody goes through.
Wine.com raised a 171 million dollars,
when I launched winelibrary.com
for 15 thousand.
- [Man Off-Screen] Okay, okay.
- And then the fucking world collapsed.
Let me promise you,
if I look at the PNL and the underbelly
of the two companies that are
giving you pressure to do...
Running your business
based on other businesses
is the quickest way to lose.
- [Man Off-Screen] Yeah.
- [Woman Off-Screen] Can you
repeat that so I can record it?
(laughs)
- Running your business
based on other business' behaviors,
especially in your industry,
especially in your scenario
is the quickest way to go out of business.
I don't know anything
that any of my competitors
have ever done, ever,
in my fucking 25-year career.
I'm aware, you can't be delusional,
you can't be audacious.
I'm aware but them
opening a fourth location,
them raising a hundred million dollars,
that doesn't dictate me
and I have pressure right
now from a lot of people
to do things that everybody else is doing
but I'm like, "I'm not building that."
- [Man Off-Screen] What about though...
- They're building to a public offering
or to a sale.
- [Man Off-Screen] What
about marketing though?
If they're on youtube...
- Build a media company.
Build a media company.
Let me explain.
- [Man Off-Screen] Yeah.
- They're advertising.
- If you can make it about you
and the stories of you,
if you can make it about yourself,
you can't beat David Letterman
by advertising 'cause
it's David Letterman.
You have to make it about you
or your team or your people or the stories
or the kids that were
underprivileged that were affected...
You have to create
something that's own able.
- [Man Off-Screen] Yeah.
- Got it?
They're building awareness,
they're gonna get theirs, brother,
but there's abundance.
Let's start with this,
market size.
Your model, done right,
is unlimited revenue.
- [Man Off-Screen] Oh, it's insane.
- Good. If you believe that
everything you're talking
about is crazy stupid.
I'm gonna help you.
If you believe that,
you're not thinking about it properly.
You're gonna get yours,
now if you got your own competitive fire
and you did the cliche thing of like,
"fuck I did this first
"and the only reason they're bigger
"is because they raised more money,
"I'm better than that."
That's fine, that's human.
We all have that.
That's not a very good
reason to start doing things
out of your comfort zone
or out of your belief
or speeding up your
process for the sake of
you don't like how the
narratives playing out right now.
"I didn't like wine.com."
All my friends from high school
and college are being like,
"oh, that's gonna be who's gonna win."
I didn't like that
but if you're good enough
you're gonna get yours.
- [Man Off-Screen] Yeah.
- You know?
- You see where I'm going.
How are you, how are you.
Hey, mate!
- How are you buddy?
- Good to see you.
- Gotta stop meeting like this, man.
- Yeah, right.
How we doin'?
- Good.
- 'Bout to go on the stage here in Denver.
Feelin' pretty good.
Feel ready, confident.
(laughs)
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
- Of course man, do your thing.
- I'm gonna say something
that I don't wanna say
because I don't wanna hurt your feelings
and I have no idea...
I don't know you
but I do wanna say this.
I need you to hear this from me,
around this conference,
it's important to me.
Please understand something that
I'm fascinated by
and I'm hoping one person hears me
and it's the time they needed to hear it.
Consuming my content, coming
to conferences like this,
reading more books, debating
about how the world should be,
being a perfectionist, debating,
complaining, dwelling, all of it.
Excuses for not doing.
If you ask me what I really want,
I want this to be the last
conference you ever go to.
I'm being dead fucking serious.
I want you to understand
that it is very likely
that if you're sitting here
you are trying to find ways not to do.
That's not everybody.
It might not even be most.
But even if one person here
uses reading 87 fucking
mindset and motivation books
and listening to 44 fucking podcasts
and 13 fucking blogs
and coming to 9 fucking
things like this a year,
if even one person here is doing that,
and by the way there's a lot more
than one person here doing that.
It's, yeah you're laughing,
'cause you know it's fuckin' true.
'Cause you know it's fuckin' true, right?
How many more fucking books
do these people need to read?
It comes down to doing.
You can figure out how
to market your business
to accomplish all your
fucking goals in life,
whether it has to build
a pool in your backyard
or to buy the fucking jets,
whatever it is,
in between, if you're actually
willing to put in the work.
You know what I do?
I fucking work 15 hours a day.
I fucking write my
captions on my Instagram.
I reply to your fucking Dms.
I answer comments.
I read my E-mail.
It's fucking work.
You want the secret, it's called work.
(cheers)
It's called work.
And by the way, do not get confused here.
You have to work
to match the ambition
coming out of your mouth.
This is not about working 15 hours a day,
you got family, you got other interests.
You do you.
But don't be a fuckin' hypocrite.
Don't be full of shit.
Don't tell me you're buying
a fucking private jet,
when you're watching four
hours of Youtube videos a day.
'Cause it's work.
You have to figure out
what you're trying to achieve
and what you want
and then you need to put in the work
that maps to that ambition.
And I know somebody's
sitting here and being like,
"yeah, Gary, you talk about hard work,
"but I work smart too, and hard!
"Now what, dick?
(laughs)
The current scientifical mathematical odds
of being born are 400 trillion to one.
Your mom might have got up
and got another glass of wine.
(audience laughs)
400 trillion to one.
You're more likely to win the megamillions
nine times in your life
than you are to even have a life.
I like data.
That's data.
We've got one life, do something about it.
Thank you.
(audience cheers)
Bye guys, thank you.
Bye.
Hello!
- Thank you so much,
this is really nice.
- A pleasure.
- How's it going?
- Really well.
- D-Rock here?
- Nope, Babin
- Nice to meet you.
- Thank you.
Okay.
- Gary, my name is Win Wolhoff.
- Hey Win.
- Nice to meet you.
- If you will face toward D-Rock
- Babin, but he likes
going by D-Rock more.
- Um, no, give me...
- You could make such a
great piece of content.
You gotta take ownership of it.
- [Babin] I just need to like accept it.
- Yeah you gotta go the other way.
That's how you win, it's a mile.
You gotta make a video
of your mom calling,
like literally put your mom on speaker
and it shows mom,
it's like...
(Phone Ringing)
- Hello?
- Hey mom, how's it goin'.
- Hey, I'm good D-Rock, how are you?
- Like, "hey mom,"
she's like, "hey, so how
are you doin' D-Rock?"
(laughs)
You guys, it's patience.
Your business is fuckin'
a second old, bro.
Like I don't even wanna
ever talk to you again
for another six years
and then...
I can't wait,
but I'm telling you.
"You're gonna be seeing me soon,"
is the biggest reason
I don't think I'm gonna
be seeing you soon.
(audience groans)
And I'm not trying to rap, I love you,
we're friends already.
But, I need everybody
to really wrap their
fucking head around this.
I'm gonna make it very clear.
On my children's health,
I believe I'm just starting.
I am so early in the process
it will make your head spin.
Cool, nice things are happening,
I understand.
From where I'm going,
what I'm actually up to.
I'm in the first inning.
Being seen soon.
This and that,
even that question is
completely inappropriate,
coming from love,
this early on.
A lot more organic, like a lot more,
like 20 hours a day.
If you want it that bad,
because the alternatives,
you're gonna go work somewhere.
Right?
So to me it's like, people are like,
"man..."
But when I tell them,
18 hours of community management,
searching hashtags, putting out content,
more videos.
I got 147 pieces of content a week,
but I did way more tweets when
it was just me and my phone.
Fuck, Twitter wasn't even mobile,
I forgot it was on a fucking desk top...
The answers a lot more,
my biggest piece of advice
is that you think in 10
and 20 and 30 year terms
for real.
Not just in a Tweet,
not just to me here right now,
your actions.
Let me just say one more time,
'cause I need somebody...
I know I need somebody to hear it here.
From the day I started
running that wine business
at 22 years old, 'til I was 34.
12 years I worked 15 hours a day,
six or seven days a week,
in a liquor store,
12 years in a row,
15 hours a day,
in a liquor store,
have no social life,
never paid myself over
150 thousand a year,
left at 34 to start with AJ Baner Media,
had zero percent ownership of Wine Library
which means I have no collateral
to get a loan or any leverage with a bank
for anything in business
and had no money in my bank account.
I was 34.
I'd already built a 16
billion dollar business
not for myself.
That's called patience.
So when I spit it to you.
I'm not coming from
hypocrisy or a high-horse,
I live it.
I'm leaving millions of
dollars on the table every year
for patience.
The answers a lot more.
See ya!
- Give me a little close-out.
- On the way to Chicago.
Got some big Vayner Media
stuff there tomorrow.
Try to meet up with somebody tonight
that would make the internet very excited.
Babin was tremendous,
continues to separate himself from D-Rock
in so many ways.
Denver's energy was tremendous.
Great audience.
Talked a lot about patience,
just, reinforcing your beliefs,
executing on your beliefs.
Been dead silent for the last 14 minutes.
Just replying to people on Twitter,
answering business questions.
Putting in the work,
putting in the work you know,
so many people
are looking for the answer.
The answers are super basic.
They just don't wanna hear the truth.
You can read about it, watch about it.
Come up with excuses why
somebody else got it.
This is an inside game,
nobody's taking your money.
Nobody else's business
is doing anything to you.
You're doing it to yourself and
either you're putting in the work smart,
strategic work or you're not.
The reason you're not
isn't because you're lazy.
It's 'cause you're not
passionate or you don't see it
or you've lost your way or
something else is bothering you
and so...
Just trying to force people
to understand how good it is,
how much opportunity there is.
I want this so badly for you.
I want it so badly for you.
'Cause I've gotten mine.
So what happens after
you've been fulfilled?
You start overflowing
and you want people to pick up on it.
The greatest hero to ever be alive.
Right now.
I don't give a shit what
the fuckin' TV tells you.
("Handskin" by Spacio)